breaking news tonight Fox News has
learned that US attorney for the
Washington DC recommended bringing
criminal charges against disgraced
former deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
well that was for lying to investigators
about leaking to the media
McCabe's team appealed the decision to
the Deputy Attorney General mr. Rosen
who rejected it but that didn't stop
MSNBC naturally from defending the cave
even as DOJ tries to make the point that
it's straight-up on the merits it'll be
very hard for people to believe when you
see all the evidence like that of the
commander-in-chief's wanting to bring
him down now it appears the department
is going to prosecute him with an
extremely weak case
a case that looks political the only
difference between Andy McCabe's case
and that of other Department employees
over the years is that the president
called for him to be fired and called
for him to be prosecuted well he doesn't
even work at their network joining me
now is Rudy Giuliani yeah Giuliani I'm
sorry I'm laughing Rudy president
Trump's personal attorney
Rudy which MSNBC contributor do you
predict McCabe will hire as his next
counsel I wouldn't hire I would hire any
of them as a lawyer but I mean the fact
the fact is that McCabe disgraced the
FBI first of all by leaking FBI agents
by the way you're not supposed to leak
if that MSNBC reporter knows of a lot of
them have done it over the years I like
know who they are but beyond that he
compounded it by lying about the leaking
to Comey unless he's lying and Comey is
telling unless Comey is telling the
truth or he's telling the truth we just
don't know so McCabe McCabe is the one
in the middle right now he's the first
step I think the next step you're going
to see is the Pfizer affidavit and
warrant which is going to turn out to
have been even worse because Comey
didn't just make a false statement Comey
lied under oath clearly without any
doubt when he made it appear as if the
steel dossier was vindicated and
verified which it wasn't so I think this
is the beginning of investigating and
bringing out the real crime
took place here which is honestly what
appears to be an emerging conspiracy to
frame Donald Trump in which I think it's
get much broader it's gonna involve
intelligence services as well but also
to vindicate Hillary Clinton I mean that
which keep the investigation going then
ultimately to vindicate her right before
the election you know if it were a book
the the heading at the beginning would
be Peter struck a statement he laid the
whole thing out I have a plan to prevent
him from being president and I have an
insurance policy to take him out if he
becomes president actually tried to do
that's what they tried to do yeah well
CNN's Toobin Jeffrey Toobin I think he
he made a big error in his defense of
McCabe watch this is an extremely
unusual prosecution and EEMA Cade had
the right to speak to reporters that
that is beyond dispute as Deputy
Director of the FBI he he had the right
to speak to reporters there is every bit
of a sign of a vindictive crusade
against McCabe
well of course McCabe filed a lawsuit
against the Justice Department to try to
avert all of this he appealed it to
Rosen that's not good I don't know what
he's talking about
you have authority to disclose
information as long as it's in the
public interest if you're in the FBI Wow
well that's a whole new definition of
the law I mean I was I was in the
Justice Department for 17 years and I
didn't think I had the authority to
disclose information to the press that's
kind of news to me I think it violates
about 10 different rules of the Justice
Department
it could easily amount to obstruction of
justice and mccabe makes it easy because
he lied about it which is a false
statement
after all they prosecuted Martha Stewart
for a single false statement to the FBI
she wasn't an FBI agent they are
prosecuting Flynn for a single false
statement when they knew the answer to
it if we have equal justice under the
law mccabe has to be prosecuted and so
does call me you can't prosecute other
false statement cases of perjury cases
just because they're democrats or they
were helping hillary
give them immunity from the law which
Hillary got but yeah we got to stop this
now and Rudy the Inspector General's a
report also said he lied for personal
gain it wasn't for the public interest
the inspector general come on the guy
was a slaughter day gillis his wife was
running for office and they were taking
money from Clinton while they were
fixing the Clinton case if that wasn't a
well never mind I mean that these people
are these people's despicable these
people are trying to create a completely
different system of justice so that the
Clintons and the Biden's and the they
get away with bribery they get away with
taking billions from China they get away
and you they get away from taking
hundreds of millions from Russia and oh
my god you know the New York Times and
The Washington Post defends them and
then you get a single false statement in
a trap by general Flynn and they want to
they want to crucify the guy that case
should be dismissed tomorrow now I'm
saying that case may just grace it's a
disgrace to the to the Justice
Department now I still can't get over
the fact they put Paul Manafort in
solitary confinement I still came over
that another disgrace in order to get
him to lie or they basically had him in
solitary confinement for seven months
and they gave him a script to read from
and they told him if you if you say what
we told you to say we'll let you out of
solitary confinement you should go to
jail for doing that it's a disgrace to
prosecutors hey Rudy ken starr of course
former independent counsel he spoke out
on what the penalty for mccabe could be
here Watch
well the charges are apparently going to
be for misleading the FBI for lie and
for lying for it but keep talking about
misleading but we'll see exactly what
the indictment says and only when we see
the indictment but we could be looking
at prison time here I can't tell you how
many people come up to me Rudy when I
travel around the country saying is
anyone gonna go into jail here
why is there no accountability for these
leaks vindictive prosecutions set up
surveillance lying to the FISA Court and
people just get
so demoralized I'm telling it like
military people don't get away with this
stuff they get thrown away for 20 years
there are a lot of Americans Laura who
still believe that justice is blind and
it doesn't matter if you're a crook and
you're a Democrat or you're a crook in
you're Republican but you go to jail but
right now we have a system of justice
that I believe Obama originally
organized what holder in which Democrats
get away with egregious criminal conduct
egregious multi-millions and bribes and
Republicans get prosecuted for processed
crimes that you wouldn't prosecute
anyone for and we have to change that if
we have crooked Republicans put them in
jail I did if you have crooked Democrats
put them in jail and the New York Times
and The Washington Post enable all this
with their ridiculous coverage Rudy
Nadler is moving forward with the
process and the in the process being put
in place for impeachment Alexandra
Acacio Court says she decided to shimon
today on the vote that she wants to see
coming out of this what's all that
genius yep yeah let's we'll have to do
our job and I think that once the house
impeaches the house has impeach the
president
and then that hearing goes to the Senate
if they want to fail it then I want to
see every Republican go on the record
and knowingly vote against impeachment
of this president knowing his corruption
having it on the record so that they can
have that stay on their crews for the
rest of their lives Rooney take a swing
at that one well I think that as a
lawyer and as a person who values
justice of course they shouldn't impeach
my political head says okay Cortez do it
and you're going to lose the house you
think those 40 Democrats that were
elected in swing districts that voted
for Trump you think those people gonna
get reelected if you do something so
stupid as impeach the whole case is
falling apart it's not only now proven
that Trump didn't do anything wrong
it's beginning to emerge that the
Democrats set them up call me McCabe
people in the intelligence community 60%
Americans
you know impeachment
you know what we call what they did in
New York law enforcement circles it was
a frame-up designed in the Obama White
House to get a dirty information from
Ukraine England Italy any place they
could get it some of the clearly
falsified I should go to jail for that
Wow wait long no matter what you're a
Democrat you want to see that we want to
see these charges you are going forward
and people have to pay those fees for
what happened really thank you I'm
confident thank thank you so much for
you good to see it tonight